this is pansy the muscle dancer she muscles
in on every party now meet Rip Van raspberry
and his wife Lily rip has a fine family tree
that explains why he's so sappy pansy as a
watchmakers daughter so she's giving rip the
works get that Mae West technique looks like
pansies gonna have him come up sometime listen
to pansy I've got him in the palm of my hand
ripest bugs about fancy and he's itching for
her looks as if he means business but it looks
like monkey business ah wife she used to be the
apple of his eye but now she's just applesauce
Lily tells him if he doesn't quit pansy she's
going to leave this cruel world and rip being
a gentleman is glad to help her out he gets
her a glass because he feels drinking poison
out of a bottle isn't sanitary taykitty says
you'll be doing me a poisoning favor Tripp
tells her this one is on the house so long
I won't be seeing you it's all more than
Lily can swallow pansy is still owing her
clutch I've got him in the palm of my hand
rip takes a look at the liquor the liquor
reminds him of poison and that reminds him
of his wife it's breakfast time so fancy
a script for a little toast rip being
well-bred thinks he's a hot toast master
here's mud in your eye rip takes another
look at the whiskey and finds his wife
coming through the ride watch this Lily
had another breakdown ripp sees the face on
the dining room floor and goes half crazy
he's only 50% nuts because his better half is gone
ah her away take her away Andy is still exercising
rip is still wrestling with his [ __
] either way it match as he thinks of
Lily's cruel fate he acts as if he isn't
normal only he's not acting rip takes it
so hard he has to take it easy ah he's
starting again the human lemon squeezer
is back rip wants to resist her but he has
to fall for her again just the fall guy what
Lily only painted the bell saved her and
her seconds take her back to her corner
rips friend how's tansy she made him unconscious
but pansy knows he was always unconscious pansy
always comes through in a squeeze and here
it comes I've got him in the palm of my hand